[Music]
we have loved her work in shows like
Glee
and movies like Best in Show and The
Ballad of Ricky Bobby and 40 year old
virgin and movies like wreckit-ralph as
well four-time Emmy Award winner Golden
Globe winner and back once again with
Hollywood game night on NBC another
season debuts next Thursday July 11th at
9:00 Eastern Time great to see Jane
Lynch so good to see you rich how are
you I'm good how you feeling now how's
the passion level you know what it's
funny when as soon as I went in my rant
at the end of our number one and I went
back and sold you I think how would you
describe me when I walk back into that
greenroom Jane it was almost like a
grave injustice perpetrated upon yes
humanity yes because mine there was a
sadness and there was a frustration and
kind of a resignation and I want it and
I hugged you you did hug me and I needed
it I needed yes and you called you
yourself a palate cleanser you're like
I'm gonna come on out and we're gonna
have a good time and I don't want to
deny where you're at though okay so
exactly where you are and you know we
can we can talk about the next I can
talk about James no no no no you're from
Chicago right so I really don't care but
I'll pretend I care you as a Cubs fan no
yeah that if the White Sox ever get the
better of the town it will be difficult
to reverse that exactly yeah and you
know the Cubs are always on top even
when they were losing and the White Sox
won the World Series a year that's
correct we still we still love our
cubbies you know I'm from the south side
I should be a White Sox fan right I am
NOT I am a Cubs fan through and through
diehard although I couldn't tell you
anything about the team right now it is
like it doesn't interest me anymore
because I live here right but I the
whole idea and the mythos around the
Cubs and Wrigley Field is the boys of
summer it really feels great a spot as
you can I mean it looked it looked when
I first walked into Wrigley Field the
the first thing I thought of for real
cuz I'm you know I think of everything
in terms of pop culture and whatever my
favorite movies are I thought of Blazing
Saddles remember how that is they built
the fake rock Reggie yes it's what it
looked like like you guys go
you could push the scenery over yeah
right I remember being a kid and walking
up the spiral the concrete steps and
then you get to where your seat is and
all of a sudden this field appears
before you and it's stunning but it is
it almost feels like a painting like a
Hollywood flat exactly but if the White
Sox ever got the better of the Cubs in a
situation where the Cubs were
patently horrible for 20 years that's
some kind of painting you know I
appreciate that you feel my pants I do
failure and you also you know I can hear
the Chicago accent in you a little you
said that and that dad kind of puts to
rest about hello I mean III thought that
I was pretty neutral but I'm not well I
just just the way you just said the word
not not I'm not neutral that's tricky
and help but I'm from the south side of
Chicago so when I'm from when when being
from the yard all you need to do is just
cut me off in traffic yeah and it'll
come it comes out it does yeah it's just
a natural part of my world yeah it's
like I'm a primitive voice you just got
to go right back yeah exactly
Jane Lynch here on the Rich Eisen show
so it's great to see Hollywood game not
gonna be back on yeah sure here come
it's all summer long and we're
ostensibly at my summer home so it's a
whole different set and we have a pool
in the backyard the pool of course is
filled with they don't it's a ball pit
really and we do a lot of games back
there on the astroturf right it's very
summery and everybody wears surf clothes
and oh okay nice I'm bikini the whole
time that's really forward to that or
not know we call that a crowd-pleaser
chain that's called a crowd-pleaser
that's called a crowd-pleaser for sure
so and then we've got like our our next
guest next our Matt Iseman zon the first
Akbar Joel McHale is on it as well
Lester Holt yeah Lester Holt is great
and a lot more fun than you would think
yeah cuz did he have the whole shot a
Lester no no excuse me you know when you
think of the guy who's telling you that
the world is crumbling right he has a
bit of a flat affect
he does he does and he's kind of very in
a very neutral kind of passive place but
he lets go a little bit for Lester Holt
okay you know a Chicago boy too so we
kind of bond on that you know back in my
stand-up days oh how about that I did
not know that you were Steve I did back
in ice one of my bits out a bit did you
one firm excuse me I had more bits you
don't you've never heard my bit know
this before I was born
okay anyway one of my bits was and I'm
sure many other comics did it was the
the news anchor voice do they still have
that when they come home for dinner
right stuff like that I'm home what's
for dinner you like you know that I it
worked in the 80s it killed no but I'm
thinking like again no no in it and it's
true and I bet those people do like that
at home I bet there's some truth to that
like Scott Hanson it's got well you know
well Bill Curtis is that there's the
king of oh yeah that anchor voice yes
these divorce effect of the anchorman
and from Chicago right exactly is he
still Bill Curtis um I just always
remember his ABC News Channel seven when
I was in Chicago for Northwestern
graduate school yes this is like this is
your life right now I'm revealing a lot
teaching what not know that you yes I
did for a year I'm a graduate school I
remember watching Bill Curtis yeah and
he always talked about when it got cold
it would be heat they call it the
Siberian Express he's pulling into town
and he would always talk that way ya
know Curtis is he still alive is he
still alive 78 years ago yeah god bless
him he was yeah he was an institution
Floyd Kalber and well do you remember
these guys
I don't you tog oh yeah you were there
probably in the eighties yeah I was
there in the eighties and nineties yeah
Carol Marino was still there yeah
Jane Lynch here on the Rich Eisen show
we've got a whole bunch of start bench
cuts I like to play with you here so
it's this is like this is you're
creating a team well I mean you've got
the Hollywood game night right so we're
gonna give you three choices it's kind
of like that Mary you know what kill
games yes did you have to start one
bench one cut one it's a version okay
start bench sit down to be quiet or cut
up okay we've got three for you here
with Jane Lynch again a Hollywood game
night back on the air
next Thursday July 11th at 9:00 Eastern
Time
you are a two-time Emmy award-winning
host yes this program yes first one
start bench cut best game show host in
the history of television okay Bob
Barker
Pat Sajak Dick Clark my favorite up
there okay you want to go off the board
here I'm probably gonna go off the board
but I'll wait yes about that by the way
that is a Joker's wild phrase right
that's a gameshow phrase if you want to
go for the moment Bob Barker's start Pat
Sajak a bench and Dick Clark cut Wow
I didn't think he was a great game show
host no and then I would have liked for
gene Rayburn gee oh yeah match the man's
game which was my one of my favorite
things in the world to watch with
Charles Nelson Reilly and Brett Somers
what else did she do other than get
drunk on that game show by the way I
will I will geek out with you on this
because I'm a gameshow freak are you oh
oh gosh yeah again I'm just I'm
revealing so I love Rich Eisen I love
all that he's opened us up to in terms
of what goes on in that head of it thank
you very much so no I'm gonna yeah
what's the name of the show in the month
right absolutely it's a show so on the
top it would always used to be just like
celebrity fill in the blank that was
like an omnibus spot on the match game
right right he's like on occasion Tom
Bosley might be there on one day or the
guy who played the guy was in charge of
Charlie's Angels I forget his name right
now he used to be up there as well so he
played Bosley you David Doyle David
Doyle great pull right there a great
imitation as well okay and that would be
Brett Somers and Charles Nelson Reilly
sure
richard Dawson richard Dawson would be
on the bottom and they hated him by the
way are you sure they despised him and
they were so happy when he went to do
family feud they they really really
couldn't
get rid of richard dawson sunglasses the
last three seasons because they all
hated eating people I'm sure that was
weird
richard Dawson was yes oh yes he did
yeah and by the way he also his best
game show hosting wasn't Family Feud
movie it was the running man yeah if
you're seeking out for sure no I'm not
done yet
because Betty White always used to be in
the right item and then Fannie Flagg
would be yes excellent so gene Rayburn
is your choice yeah bring microphone the
long microphone and he was funny himself
and he really knew how to set those guys
up and let them he really knew how to
allow the game to like just explode into
fun and then come in and enforce the
rules and I try to do that myself on
Hollywood game okay that's very Rayburn
s crazy Bob but Bob Barker's is he's the
one oh he's the winner and what a great
man he was to animal lover and I met him
once
oh did you yes again sharing yes Bob
Barker yes so I met him once
oh he's still with us oh god bless him
yes he could give away cash and prizes
today if he was so kind and gentle so I
went up to him at this event where for
Dog Rescue was getting an award my wife
and I are a big dog I know it share the
same we have the same dr. Mahaney yes
blessing everyone oh my gosh I'm trying
to balance the void that I have in my
life with James Dolan mix owner oh it's
okay
just bear with me that's all I'm asking
we're bearing Barry where was oh yeah so
here I'm with Bob Barker and I went up
to him and I said to him Bob just you
know we've never met before and I
sometimes I roll the dice maybe he's a
sports fan he does know me he had no
idea who the hell I was but I went up to
him and I told him I'm the host of the
NFL Network which I just started doing
and I told him about how I get to speak
to so many different people from
different walks of life the Hall of
Famers rookies keep kids from the city
kids from rural areas and I just the way
that he welcomes people to contestants
row I told him that I learned I learned
from him
on how to talk to people and how to
treat everyone the same way and I just
want to say thank you Bob Barker he
pauses and he looks at me and he says do
you want to hug it out and I'm like yes
as a matter of fact I do yes and I
hugged it out Barker Barker he said hug
it out he's quote do you want to hug
what a great guy alright next one for
start bench cut we went down a little
bit Barker as well we should
okay next one for Jane Lynch here which
former co-star would make a great
celebrity player on Hollywood game night
okay okay Christopher Guest from Best in
Show
Steve Carell from 40 year old virgin or
Will Ferrell from Talladega Nights story
with those guys would be on my show
number one you must start you must bench
you must cut okay well I would cut
Christopher guest's for his own good
because he would be praying for me to
cut it I both Steve and will I would I
would start do I have to do I'm gonna
bench Steve and I'm gonna cut and he'd
probably thank me too okay and I'm going
to start well so yeah I'll just come out
and like shorts whatever absolutely he'd
have a bless he in fact he's the type of
guy that maybe even though he's a huge
movie star he might do my show he was
maybe okay there you go
Will Ferrell start that one next one
last one here for Jane Lynch which role
was the biggest stretch for you to play
Oh start bench cut okay here are the
three choices
Sue Sylvester and glee teacher research
dr. Cathy Wallen from the fugitive yeah
or FBI agent Russo and collateral damage
with the Afro mention Arnold
Schwarzenegger yes no no are you saying
that this is the hardest or the get the
hardest stretch for you to play biggest
stretch bench cut so start would be the
biggest stretch cut would be the the
easiest Oh cut it was easy okay Cathy
wall and bench okay agent Russo because
I had my neck broken in that
start that was the hardest to do and
also you had to believe that I had my
net broke neck broken by a woman who was
about 5 foot 2 97 pounds who was that
doing
she was his co-star in this and we don't
think it was the coach checking it could
it be could it be Maria Conchita Alonso
could it be it came out right after 9/11
and it was about terrorists that's know
a friend and chest canary there we go
yeah so it's very believable then that
you made it believable there's so much
yeah because there's no way that that I
was like supposed to be an FBI trained
person and I allowed this little girl to
jump on me and break my neck right how
often do you hear about the fugitive
from people a lot you know the fugitive
is one of those movies as you probably
know that it is timeless it was a big
hit when it came out and people still go
back and watch it like I'll hear people
say you know it came up on television
and I you watched all this it's for us
here on this show well that may flat out
remote drop like literally it's a remote
Trump like five minutes in it's your
movie walnut one our man is doing his
thing and you know the train crash
hasn't even happened yet and you're like
oh god do I have two hours Andrew Davis
huh as collateral damage no can director
mm-hmm how about that yeah that's how I
got that job no bone every no it's funny
the NBA Draft this year took place in
the same hotel as the big R rdu-90
reveal finish just to show you again how
much of a wow you've a nice movie I do
know this yeah Wow am I free to not at
all I think I love you even more I love
I love somebody who's curious and
well-rounded and curious about all
aspects of life because I'm not at all I
I just I like coffee I like sitting at
home by myself
they asked me before would you rather be
on an island with one person or by
yourself and like totally
myself even if I like that person I
totally no kidding just sit there and
ponder me my name well you know it's
funny that we have bonded over a love of
I guess what game shows Fannie Flagg
realize I only know a little bit but
everything just to get by anything that
much wears you are mark like in a
walking with but not Wikipedia you're
more I am I use what I am if you don't
mind I don't mind I don't normally do
this sort of thing describe myself I am
a font of useless information that's
fantastic literally have it through my
years on the planet unknowingly yeah
sucked in all of this information well
you know it is the era of the nerd now
we are exalting you people thank you hey
it's a it's a badging of uh nerds are in
nerds are in that's what she's trying to
say
nerds are in yeah nerds are totally in
yeah okay yeah very good Hollywood game
night returns on NBC July 11 and 9:00
Eastern Time
very pleased to have you on oh really
good to see you again thank you for
coming on as you know I'm now your pain
I'm facing it and I am gonna get through
it and let it go and then let it go you
change the new reality and don't ever
step foot in Madison Square Garden I
don't think I'm gonna be allowed to as a
matter of fact I don't think I'm gonna
be allowed to NBC again home of
Hollywood game night July 11th at 9:00
Eastern Time Jane Lynch at Jane Marie
Lynch on Twitter and at Jane Lynch
official on Instagram deed thank you for
coming on next time I wear pants I
didn't realize my legs I thought these
were like a Capri Takao Joey Joey is now
my new favorite word know that existed
I see now I'm gonna take that in yes and
in about fifteen years from now I'm
gonna spit it out you'll be a font of
information you know the history of God
shows and by the way just like Bob
Barker you asked me if you want to be if
I needed a hug and hug it out and I said
yes see that's what Emmy Award game show
hosts do from
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app